en Cuba también votan este domingo en
concreto para sus elecciones municipales
el presidente Miguel Díaz canel
reivindicó la celebración de los
comicios proceso electoral
mantiene la estabilidad política
mantiene su estabilidad social
independientemente del primero de
recrudecimiento de la batalla económica
la batalla de asfixia económica que nos
están tratando de implantar para que la
población por el descontento por la
desesperanza por lo agobio de todas las
las carencias vayan al lado estallido
social que tiene el gobierno
imperial que es aplicar la lógica
imperialista en estas elecciones se
escogen los delegados que conforman las
asambleas municipales del poder popular
no pueden hacer campaña y las
nominaciones son en reuniones vecinales
donde se tiene en cuenta méritos
personales sino posiciones políticas por
lo que no tienen que pertenecer al
partido comunista entre sus funciones la
gestión directa de problemas y quejas en
las comunidades además de Pro que el 50%
de los candidatos a las asambleas
provinciales y al parlamento elección
legislativa que tendrá lugar en 2023 es
importante muy importante porque así se
representa el pueblo en
la asamblea la oposición sin embargo
había pedido a la ciudadanía la
abstención denuncian que se les ha
impedido en gran medida participar en
unas elecciones marcadas por la grave
crisis económica que vive Cuba